- All right, welcome back!
Even though Valentine's Day was Monday,
you might still have a
few picked over chocolates
in that classic heart
shaped box lying around.
Not in my house but some people might.
If you do, our favorite Rustic
Joyful Food cookbook author
has a delicious way to
transform those leftover treats.
Please welcome back, Danielle Kartes!
(Kelly whooping)
- Yes, oh my gosh.
I'm so excited to be here.
- This is awesome.
I love my job.
What are we making?
- You guys, a lava cake is
like old school cruise ship
but it never goes outta style.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I love these things.
Okay, so you know how
you were talkin' about
how you never have the chocolate left?
You know how you nibble on
one and it's kinda weird?
- Yeah.
And you're like, oh no.
- Then you're like, oh
no, I don't like it.
But then you're hard
up a couple days later
and you're like, I'm gonna eat that.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, so this is a great way, these little
Valentine's cakes are a great way
to use up all the chocolate.
- Okay.
- So first thing we're
gonna do, in your little
pretty bowl over there,
you've got eggs and sugar
and chocolate already melted.
- I'm in.
- [Danielle] You are in.
And next thing we're
gonna do is add our flour.
Sprinkle your flour across the whole top
because you don't wanna over mix this.
We're not trying to overwork our flour.
And when you overwork your flour,
that actually means you're
developing the gluten.
You don't wanna do that.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- Put your little vanilla in.
- Okay.
- Put your salt in.
Sprinkle 'em all over, all the salt.
- Okay.
- We like it salty.
- I like it salty.
- And when you stir,
take your spatula, this is
so cool, I don't know why.
I always feel like cooking's
like therapy for me.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- I just love it.
- [Kelly] Especially baking.
- Yes!
- Okay, so go down the middle.
Stir and fold.
(Kelly gasps)
Go all around the outside.
- What?
- Down the middle, stir and fold.
- How have I never learned this?
- Yes!
This is makes you not have a tough cake.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- You know when you're
baking your own cake,
I mean, shout out to box mix.
I love a box mix.
There's no shame in it.
- Look, sometimes you don't have time.
- You don't have time.
And we choose box mix.
I mean, my kids choose it.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- My vanilla cake is like, whatever.
(audience laughs)
So here, go in and you just barely wanna
get all the flour gone.
- Okay.
- Keep on goin'.
- [Kelly] You barely, so you
still wanna see a little?
- You barely, you just wanna,
even if you see a couple bits
and little streaks of flour, it's fine.
- Okay.
I am done.
- So here we go.
And then here's my other
little superhero tip.
Your ice cream scoop wants more
action than just ice cream.
- Aye!
- Isn't that cute?
- So here, grab him up.
- Okay.
- You're gonna use your ice cream scoop.
These little ramekins are
already buttered and floured.
So you can bring 'em on over.
It's supposed to mitigate
mess but I'm pretty messy.
- I love a mess.
- Right?
- [Danielle] If you
just get it everywhere.
- [Kelly] It means you had a good time.
- I know.
Probably three scoops in here.
- Okay.
- And this is the fun part.
Look it.
You get to take your little chocolates.
- [Kelly] God, that looks so good.
Your little half eaten, oh, they're taped.
See, they're so cute.
- Okay, so you take the half eaten ones.
- Put the chocolate in.
- Okay.
- Just shove 'em in there.
- Oh!
You just kind of push
it down in so it melts?
- Push 'em down in there,
yep, 'til he melts.
- Oh!
- If you don't have a chocolate,
you can use a teaspoon
of peanut butter.
- Mine.
- Yes.
You can do some Nutella.
- Oh my god, I love Nutella.
- How cute would that be?
So next, here we come over, let's pretend
- [Kelly] This isn't done.
- By the magic of our, no, it's not done.
But he's baked.
- Oh, it's baked.
That's what I meant, yeah.
- Yes, okay.
- Okay.
- Here's our cute lil' cake.
Take your caramel.
You have warm caramel next to it.
- Oh, god.
- Shake him out of there.
- Shake it up.
- Shake him, shake him.
- Oh, yeah.
- And then now we get to cut into him.
- [Kelly] Okay, fine.
- Look it, look it.
- Fine, fine.
- I wanna like, show everybody
so you can see the goo.
(Kelly gasps)
- Does it come out?
- It's supposed to ooze.
- Yeah!
- Look it, look it, look it.
Yes.
- I love this job so much.
I love you.
- And, ugh, I love you too.
- And then because we like to do extra.
- Oh!
I do!
- If you wanna just cut the sweet,
we have some more sweet to cut the sweet.
You know you need ice cream.
- You know what?
And if you don't wanna, you can do this.
- Look, watch this.
- Yeah.
- You just take a bite.
- I'm just gonna double it up.
(audience laughs)
Look it, put 'em on in the middle.
- Oh my god, it's so good.
- And you know what?
- I have never met anybody
that doesn't like this.
- I can't be friends with
someone that doesn't like this.
I know people who don't
like chocolate, it's weird.
- I don't, how can you not like chocolate?
- [Kelly] I don't know, it's so good.
- That's a gross person.
I mean, I'm sorry but
- I wish I didn't.
(both laugh)
- If you don't wanna do
the little guy like this,
in my book, I'm talking
with my mouth full,
we have a one pan lava cake.
Just put it in one pan and scoop it out.
- Oh, yeah!
- Like raw brownie.
- Oh my god, you are
speaking my love language.
- Here's the thing,
- Yeah.
- We fight over in my house,
who's gonna lick the bowl?
- Mhm.
- Yeah.
- We share.
All right, well, everybody,
you can get this full recipe
on our Facebook page.
Thank you so much Danielle.
This is delicious!
(audience claps)
- You're welcome.
- [Kelly] It is so good.
My mouth is so happy.
- Yeah.
- It's throwing a private party.
And be sure to follow
Danielle on Instagram
@rustandjoyfulfood and pick
up Danielle's three part
cookbook series, Rustic Joyful
Food wherever books are sold.